the movie The Matrix everyone thinks
science fiction I go no no that's a
documentary everybody got programmed
that's a fact that's a biological
reality but what was interesting they
always say well there's a red pill and
if you take the red pill you get out of
the program and I go guess what almost
everybody in our audience is taking that
red pill at one time change their life
it turns out science has recognized that
when you fall in love you stop playing
the programs and you start creating from
your conscious mind wishes and desires
are conscious mind and so once you let
go of a program and you start creating
wishes and desires it's called the
honeymoon created this heaven on Earth
experience and I go you could have that
every day for every day of your whole
life because we created that and if you
understand you created then you can say
well why don't I create it tomorrow and
I go you can create it every day that's
the beautiful part hi I'm Bruce lion
author of the bestselling books the
biology belief spontaneous Evolution and
the honeymoon effect I'm here to thank
Evan carmichel for featuring me on his
YouTube channel and I want to let you
know that Evan is giving away links
where you can watch the First episodes
of my special guia series entitled inner
Revolution for free evidence making this
offer to thank you for watching this
video you will find the links in the
description section below thank you hey
it's EV Carmichael and I make these
videos because I need them because I
want to wake up every single day and get
pushed by somebody who's doing a lot
more than me and in watching their
videos it inspires me to be bolder to
have more courage and chase down the
life of my dreams and I hope it does the
same for you so today let's learn how
you can manifest your future
enjoy here is a practical technique the
first thing you do you must know exactly
what you want in this world when you
know exactly what you want make as
lifelike a representation as possible
suppose I wanted a home but I had no
money but I still know what I want I
without taking anything into
consideration I would make as lifelike a
representation of the home that I would
like with all the things in it that I
would want and then this night as I
would go to bed I would in a state a
drowsy sleepy State I would imagine that
I am actually in such a house that would
I to step off the bed I would step upon
the floor of that house were I to leave
this room I would enter the room that is
adjacent to my imagined room in that
house and while I am touching the
furniture and feeling it to be solidly
real and while I am moving from one room
to the other in my imaginary house I
would go sound asleep in that state and
I know that in a way I could not
consciously devise I would realize my
house I have seen it work time and time
again if I wanted promotion in my
business I would ask myself what
additional responsibilities would be
mine were I to be given this great
promotion and then in my imagination I
would begin to see and touch and do and
act as I would outward see and touch and
act were I in that position rule number
three is change your old personality
with Joe dispenza how you think and how
you feel creates your state of being if
you take a thought and a feeling a
thought and a feeling a thought and a
feeling a thought and a feeling that's
called an attitude a series of good
thoughts with a series of Good Feelings
you say I have a good attitude today you
have a series of negative thoughts that
are connected to a series of negative
feelings you say I have a bad attitude
today so attitudes are just shorten
states of being good attitude in the
morning bad attitude in the afternoon if
you take an attit ude and attitude and
at you keep those up and you string
attitudes together you create what's
called a belief and a belief is just an
extended state of being so if you keep
thinking the same thought you keep
hardwiring in the brain you keep feeling
the same feeling you keep conditioning
in your body the redundancy of that
cycle over and over again conditions the
body to subconsciously become the mind
of that belief and all beliefs are
subconscious states of being okay take a
belie belief a belief a belief and you
string them together you form what's
called a perception and perceptions are
just such extended states of being that
that we're unconscious and so then we we
edit out reality in fact most people
don't see things the way they are they
see things the way they are yes right
and people are always feeling in reality
unconsciously based on their memory they
could be married to a person for 40
years and they don't see the person they
see the memory of the person right and
there's research to prove this okay so
how do we change a belief or perception
about our s for our lives okay we've
studied
this okay let's just say that lack is
ingrained in there you got the story you
lived on the streets you lost everything
you got betrayed your business partner
took everything took your wife took you
got the story in the half okay okay you
got to start telling a new story of the
future right you got to believe in that
future more than you have to believe in
the past so how do you do that you only
believe in the past when you feel feel
the emotions of the past the only time
you're going to believe in the future is
when you feel the emotions of the future
right okay so in order for us to change
a belief or perception about our self
and our
lives we have to make a decision with
such firm
intention that the amplitude of that
decision carries a level of energy
that's greater than the hardware
programs in your brain and the emotional
conditioning in your body and your body
literally has to respond to your mind
that the choice that you're making to
change in that moment becomes a moment
in time that you never forget and here's
the key physically physically the
stronger the emotion you feel when you
make that choice the more you remember
the decision okay so then how do we
downregulate that old belief if the
trauma created an emotional quoti of six
or seven then your decision to change
your belief's got to be a nine right and
you got to come out of your resting
state and that that moment has to Define
you you could say I know exactly where I
was the time and day it was who I was
with when I made my mind up to change
right cuz you created a long-term memory
long-term memories are created from
strong emotions right but the amplitude
of that emotion is greater than the
Betrayal Boom the body starts responding
to the mind and you're actually giving
your body a taste of the future
emotionally so you brand your possible
no your body is actually getting the T
tast of that future event it's
experiencing the future now exactly big
explosion in the quantum field big
explosion so the side effect of that is
if you combine that clear intention with
that elevated emotion you're basically
remembering your future and it looks no
different than remembering your past
think neurologically within the circuits
of that memory and feel within the
emotions of that new belief and watch
your life begin to change because
nothing changes in our life that we
change it when we change our energy we
change our life so now the experiment
all of a sudden is no longer based on it
being hard or trying or wishing or
wanting or hoping that's what we do when
we're lack or in lack or separation it's
about change so then when we finally
realize in order for
us to become abundant we have to
overcome the old personality rule number
four is improve your awareness with eart
tole in this world dealing with
things create things achieving
things and being is
about being aware
of the present
moment which after all is all you ever
have
whatever you achieve through becoming in
the future
eventually turns into the present
moment so as I speak to
you the meditation if we even want to
call it
that it's perhaps best to forget about
the
word as I
speak be aware of
the St the silence or the
Stillness between the
words being aware means just notice that
it's there it's very
simple
so you notice
that in addition to the
words there's another
dimension that is easily
overlooked and that's the dimension
of Stillness
which we could also
call
space
or
spaciousness so when you
notice that there are
two so to
speak two
Dimensions
here the dimension
of
Words which
you
hear and which then
become
thoughts in your
head and
the dimension
of no
thing
spaciousness you just so you just notice
that's all that's
required that there is that Dimension
also present so you notice
it
in between
words and
even behind the
words so to
speak now when you notice
it what
happens inside you what does it mean to
notice
the
Stillness be aware of the
Stillness it
means you have become
still
inside it
means
you're
conscious but at that moment at this
moment you're not
thinking but you're
alert
present completely
here but not
thinking
so that's the
realization of the dimension of
depths within you rule number five is
practice proper manifestation with Gabby
Bernstein I keep doing all the work I'm
doing all the things I'm meditating I'm
praying doing everything but nothing's
changing okay what do I do I love it
okay so I'm meditating I'm praying I'm
doing everything but nothing's changing
dear Gabby help I got you I get that one
it's a big one well sounds like there a
little bit of manic manifesting
happening little bit of really pushing
and trying to make something happen and
if you've heard me talk about what it
takes to
manifest it actually takes a lot more
spiritually aligned
action and so I actually first I'm going
to say go back and listen to the episode
on spiritually aligned action the whole
method or go to super attractor and read
that chapter in the book all about
taking spiritually aligned action but
the message here really is is that
whenever you notice yourself pushing in
any area even your spiritual
practice take a beat and recognize that
anything that we do with force or
pushing or in a way that's controlling
we're actually
blocking we're in the way
we're bleeding from a place of lack a
feeling of lack a feeling of insecurity
a feeling of neediness thirstiness
pushing that's not a sexy energy and the
universe doesn't respond to it so stop
everything stop everything take a
break
breathe enjoy a meal taste your food
have a fun conversation with a
friend sometimes we can use our
spiritual practice as another form of
controlling and we have to really be
aware of that because it's actually
quite the opposite effect that we want
it to have we're using it in form of
controlling and so we're blocking what
it is that we desire because we're
pushing controlling manipulating manic
manifesting so the answer is stop
take a
break have an ice
cream have a tea have a
coffee do nothing and let the Universe
show you what to do and rule number six
the last one before some very special
bonus Clips is create a vision board
with John asra A lot of people ask me if
I still use a vision board like I showed
in the Smash It movie The Secret and the
answer is I do but it's slightly
different than the one I used to have
I am um sitting here in Port andrax in
my arc of Spain and um this is a little
bit of uh what's been on my vision board
in the last several years if you take a
look at this area it's one of the most
beautiful little Paradise Islands
anywhere in the world surrounded by the
Mediterranean now why am i showing you
that well um this is my exception life
blueprint and in this exception life
blueprint I have pictures of my let me
just move the camera C withit my wife my
kids my family um and I have pictures of
things that I've already achieved um and
you know homes that we've either owned
jets that we've flown uh places that
we've vacationed um you know cars that
either I want to um have or U I want to
or that I do have um and experiences
that I want to enjoy um you know we
rented this in um um Mal Dives last year
um we have a home in color Rod over here
this was in uh Bali I'm sorry in um um
the South Pacific Islands of Bora Bora
um we've rented um Yachts we've been in
the most beautiful places now why am I
sharing this with you you think I'm
trying to impress you and the answer is
I'm not trying to impress you I want to
just show you something I want to
impress upon you
something first you have to get a vision
of what it is you want to trade your
life for
uh and it's not about the cars and the
houses and the and the and the trips
like what do you want to have your life
feel
like um what do you want to achieve in
your health wealth relationship career
business contribution charity
Etc the reason it's so critical to start
off with a vision even when you do not
know how to achieve it and you probably
know this I left High School a grade 11
I was voted most likely to fail um
English and math I failed in grade seven
I didn't think I was smart enough good
enough worthy enough but I had a guy by
the name of Alan Brown my first Mentor
when I was 19 that asked me like what do
you want to trade your life for what
would you like your life to be like and
he dared me to
dream and at the time I said well I'd
love a four-bedroom house i' love to get
a job that I'm making more than $165 an
hour which is what I was making in a
shipping Department of uh Philips
electronics and um I was uh doing a lot
of stuff that I shouldn't have been
doing as a you know as a teenager but he
helped me create a vision first even
though it was a fantasy it wasn't even a
fantasy it didn't even feel like it
could be a fantasy because I didn't have
any idea how to achieve it and once I
created my vision for health wealth
relationships career business fun
experiences travel Etc he said to me um
what would you need to
believe in order to achieve these things
I said well um I guess I would need to
believe that I'm smart enough he says
yes says what else would you need to
believe I said well I guess I would need
to believe that that it's possible he
says yes he said what else would you
need to believe I said I guess I would
need to believe that um it's possible
for me and that I'm worthy of it and
that I deserve it and I went on to list
all of these beliefs can he help me with
a few beliefs uh like you know I would
need to believe and have the
self-discipline uh and then he went on
to say well what would your identity
need to be like and I was like identity
what do you mean he says well everybody
has character traits that they're um
abiding by right now but in order to
achieve you know these big goals that
you have you'd have to have some new
character traits and and he said things
like self-confidence things like
certainty things like feeling empowered
things like feeling you can overcome
anything things like knowing that you
can learn anything to apply what is
needed to achieve those goals he says in
order to achieve the goals that you have
the vision that you wrote down on this
you know sheet of paper which you gave
me you have to create the identity and
the character traits to behave in those
ways you have to practice to make those
permanent in your mind so practice is
what makes permanent he says a lot of
people are practicing the wrong things
and and they're making the wrong
self-image permanent the wrong identity
permanent the wrong beliefs permanent
the wrong habits permanent he says in
order to achieve any goal you want to
achieve you have to create the right
patterns that drive the right behaviors
that achieve the results you
want what is fear is fear something that
you should fear no I want you to imagine
that you're driving down the street in
your car and a light pops up on the
dashboard a light pops up um have you
ever taken a hammer and hit the light
because you don't like the
light of course not that would be silly
right what if the light on the dashboard
was just a signal maybe your low on tire
air uh air pressure maybe uh you're
missing air or water in your windshield
wiper maybe the back trunk do is open
isn't the signal in your car just for
you to be aware that maybe something is
wrong or something needs attention is it
possible that if we stop thinking of
fear as the enemy fear is one of your
biggest friends why well when you
understand how did this
organism okay develop and how does it
Keep Us Alive it pays attention to
things okay in your external World
triggers from your external word that
could cause your death or destruction it
causes you to do what when there is a
potential thre threat predator or threat
at the door it lights up the fierce
signal sends cortisol epinephrine or
norepinephrine into your bloodstream so
you either know how to fight it you run
away or you freeze hoping that the
Predator will go away so when your brain
every
brain gets this signal that there is a
threat at the
door it sends a
signal in the form of a neurochemical
that you
feel now if
somebody feels this threat in their body
but they don't know how to manage the
emotion we call fear
let's say there's a fear that you have a
failure and what it might mean to your
family what's what about a fear of
losing money and not having enough to
pay the rent the mortgage or for
retirement what if there's a fear of
trying something and then it not working
out and you're embarrassed or ashamed or
ridiculed or rejected or judged oh my
God if you judge me then you're G to
reinforce my low self-esteem of myself
and then ho then who am I you understand
what's happening in the circuits I'm
just
describing so when our brain has this
Fierce circuit activated do you think
the fear circuit causes you to go oh hey
let's take action anyway or do you think
it goes high alert high alert high alert
be aware what's going on what if you
fail what if you succeed what if you
succeed and fail whenever that circuit
is triggered motivational circuit shuts
down whenever that circuit is activated
your thinking circuit shuts down all the
blood flow goes into a part of your
brain to help you do what possibly run
away protect yourself it's a protection
mechanism but here is what I want you to
remember this automatic Trier and
circuit has been evolving for millions
of years but your specific experiences
since you were born in the modeling
experiential a and the um and the
imprinting years caused you to have
beliefs about things some Empower you
some disempower let me give you an
example okay let me give you an example
when I say the word or let me give you a
different same example just a little
different story if I say to you that I'd
like to take a big snake about five feet
long and let it Slither across your arm
and around your neck and it's a python
how many of you go oh wow that would be
great
versus how many of you are going oh my
God let me run away get get it off of me
just just think of a snake slithering on
you and curling itself around your neck
how many of you are like run versus oh
my God that would be great can you take
a picture of me with it so I can put on
social
media so is it really the snake that is
the threat or is it your Concept in your
brain the meaning that you have
associated with a snake that is
activating for some of you the reward
center and for others the fear Center
same stake stain stimuli there isn't
even a snake here I just add you think
about it right and it triggered that
fear circuit for some rewards circuit
for others so it's never about the thing
so when we have fear of being
embarrassed ashamed ridiculed judged uh
fear of disappointing ourselves fear of
failing fear of succeeding there's 50
different types of fears we
automatically
trigger the circuit that does what stops
our action taking could you speak about
the
neurophysiology of
forgiveness
sure think
about Frozen circuits Frozen circuits
are hardwired circuits
the more profound the insult to the
person that is connected to a strong
emotion the more the brain freezes
circuitry the more we think about the
experience the more we fire and wire the
circuits in our brain yes or no yes and
the more we remember the event the more
we produce the emotions that are
associated with it and we're
conditioning the brain and body further
into the past yes or no yes and it you
keep doing it enough times it's no
longer conscious that you're holding a
grudge it's no longer conscious that
you're stuck it's now you're seeing
everybody through the lens of that
experience and everybody's a betrayer
everybody can't be trusted everybody is
that same person you're you're
overlaying the memory of re of your
experience into reality you're not
seeing it the way it is you're seeing
that person wearing the mask of the last
person that's the lens that we're
perceiving reality are you with me still
and so then anything in your life that
becomes remotely close to it based on
your limited perception triggers the
emotion and the network and you're back
in your past and you're acting like you
were when it happened are you with me
still yes and so then the person says
I'm not that person and you say oh no I
know I just had this event in my past
and I'm sorry and then it's excusable
but then here it happens again and
there's nothing wrong with this we all
do it it's just how do we overcome it so
then you're sitting and doing the work
and you're you're moving energy up those
centers you're releasing the life force
into your brain you are are blessing
those centers and taking a scoop and
moving it all the way up and releasing
it all the way up into the field you're
opening the channel you're unfolding as
nobody no one no thing nowhere and no
time and the identity and the
personality is gone energyy is going to
move it's got to it's going to follow
the
path you're opening your heart once it
gets to your heart it's going to make
its way all the way up and when you feel
love and compassion when you feel true
true kindness and care it's hard to hold
a grudge
are you with me still yes so then from
a quantum physics point of
view you have that person always in the
back of your mind right you have the
event and the memory rolling around back
there because the very thing that you
don't want to have happen you're already
preparing for emotionally are you with
me still so then from a Quantum
perspective you are actually as a
creator of reality ity holding yourself
hostage because of that person and you
are holding them hostage because of that
experience and you have an energetic
Bond that's connecting you to them and
you're sharing the same energy and so
then you're using each other to reaffirm
whatever that energetic agreement is are
you with me still so then when you
forgive someone it's because there's
been a strong change in your emotional
state cuz the emotion is what's keeping
you energetically bound to them or to
more than one person and so then once
you start lowering the volume to that
emotion and the body starts liberating
energy and you're calling your energy
back to you because the lower the volume
of the emotion the less you're going to
pay attention to that person there comes
a moment where there's a snap there's a
release the energy is broken and once
it's broken now all of a sudden you free
yourself and you free them and this has
happened to me in my life that people
show up 10 years later completely
changed and
so humble and so asking for forgiveness
just because they had transformed and
and I let them go so then
forgiveness from a Quantum perspective
and a neurophysiological perspective is
just taking your attention off them
that's all it is and when you start
getting happy with
yourself and you start feeling those
elevated emotions cuz you're striving
for that you wouldn't trade this for The
Grudge you were holding because this
feels too good are you with me still now
once that heart opens up and you start
having energy in the center and it's
releasing 1, 1300 to 14400 different
chemicals that begin to restore and
regenerate the body the body start
getting a lift of energy once it makes
its here now you're going to see that
track sending in energy to the brain the
heart acts as an amplifier to boost the
brain are you with me
still so then once the Energy starts
making its way into the brain once the
heart starts to open we've measured this
with our students they have oxytocin
levels rise once you start feeling
oxytocin when you feel more love then
you feel The Grudge so then you think
why would I want to give this up for
that person that's called forgiveness
you don't have to try to do it it just
is a side effect of your personal
transformation and oxytocin then when
it's released rushes right into the
amydala the survival center of the brain
and the research is outstanding and the
first thing it does is it fits in the
same receptor sites as fear and it
lowers the volume to fear and anxiety it
shuts the lights out for aggression and
anger and hostility and it cools the
circuits off for suffering and pain and
the only thing you can feel is a love
for life and that's when you're free now
the practice of
forgiveness matter to matter you can do
it but it's takes a long time and a lot
of work and then you forgive and then
you're like I don't want to forgive
him halfway forgive
him and just never really authentic
forgiveness do you understand and you
know there was a woman that came to our
work
and she was raped by four men when she
was a teenager and it was
abusive and she had severe severe night
terrors severe a uh uh um anxiety and
panic attacks she had cyclic mood
problems she had been to every single
doctor every single healer every single
Al alternative practitioner nothing
changed it she came to our event
in in um Tacoma
Washington and she hit that point where
she became everybody everyone everything
everywhere every time every place she
became the Oneness and the and that
frequency had a message for her and it
said and she was an incredible Bliss
when this
happened I sent Four Angels disguised as
rapists for this
moment and that was the end of her
Terrors that was the end of her night
she couldn't have a relationship she
couldn't she could not live with anybody
she was she was
isolated one moment the Divine stepped
in and gave her the signal that was
carrying a very specific message and she
got the download not just the not just
the thought she got the the energy
mooved right through her body and she
saw the whole thing and that
moment is what she was waiting for
that's what the soul was waiting for now
she's healed she's healthy she's happy
and she's on with a new life she's born
my mother would love this she's born
again in the same life reborn in the
same life didn't pass through a birth
canal for it she just was born again in
the same life she got a new lease in one
instant that energy was carrying a
message and it made its way all the way
into the body and the Bliss and the joy
and the Gratitude and the love that she
felt and the message that was carried
would made total sense to her she's free
one instant to me that's true
forgiveness that's the Divine having its
way with you just give yourself
permission to want the things that you
want and unless un you believe that
you're worthy unless that you practice
love you're never going to think that
you deserve the things that you want
right so tell the
story okay so I'm probably gonna stop
hysterically I'll shorten it I'll
shorten it so the the bottom line is is
that so in
1990 I was a senior in college at
Dartmouth and my parents came to visit
from Western Michigan and we went to
this place called Simon Pierce which is
a famous glass blowing Mill and as we
walked into the restaurant I had an
experience that you may be able to
relate to and that is I walked in and I
immediately saw this painting hanging on
the wall and it was about the size of a
door only horizontal and it was a
Vermont landscape and I was drawn into
it immediately like I was no longer in
that restaurant I was standing in that
field I could feel that breeze I'd never
ever had an experience like that with a
painting have you ever had an experience
like that with art no I mean not like
that not like that I mean my yeah my
sense was that this is very atypical for
you very so
I kind of lost it the the the the
restaurant was quiet and then I leaned
back I'm suddenly kind of back in the
moment I'm like I'm going to own this
painting someday it just that was what
was right there and I looked at the
price and it said like $33,000 I'm like
not today and I went back and I sat down
and that was it but the painting never
left my mind you see there's something
called the Zonar effect I I always say
it wrong but it's like there's a
checklist in your brain that when you
have a moment where you're like this is
important your brain puts it on a
checklist yeah there's like a notch yes
a notch happens and now your brain as
part of the filter in the brain is
always going to be kind of scanning the
subconscious to let anything into your
mind related to that incident it can be
positive by the way like with the
painting or this is how trauma happens
too like you have this high-intensity
emotional experience that notches
something in your brain and now your
brain kicks in to remember so uh bottom
line is uh I always thought about that
painting years go by whenever somebody
would say Vermont I'd think of the
painting I don't know why I can't
explain it never wanted a painting
before was not an art student it's going
to lawo like you're out collecting art
no no no and so I you know fast forward
the story 10 years and my uh H Chris and
I are are engaged and we're going to go
up to Vermont to see the leaves and
immediately I'm like we got to go to
Simon Pierce I got to show you the
painting so we pull up to the mill and
we walk in and right in front there is
Boom a painting by the same artist Gail
Shephard and I'm like oh my God it's
here and we race all around the place
and it's gone and the funny thing was
and this is the way your brain works
Chris was more disappointed than I was I
literally turned to him and said it's
okay dude like it'd be weird if we're
still here after 10 years I'm going to
track this thing down I actually said to
him you know what's going to happen
Chris I'm GNA be able to buy this like
40 years from now it's going to be
hanging in the corporate Lobby of some
building and I'm going to have to track
down the owner and pay like quadruple
the money they pay but I'm going to own
this Mission yes so a couple years pass
and um it's my birthday I think I was
turning 30 and Chris says uh Chris gets
a couple people too
give money and he said I could buy
anything I wanted with it so I had I had
what 500 bucks now I'm pregnant at the
time with our first kid I should have
bought a crib or stools but for whatever
reason the zigen arch effecta takes over
and I'm like the painting so I call the
mill and I get this guy in the phone I'm
like uh you know I want to buy a kale
Shephard piece and I said could you send
me Polaroids and he's like sure and I
tell him the budget and he goes I'll
I'll send you Polaroids of some of her
smaller things MH and like blowing up in
the meantime right yeah she's a very
very successful Vermont landscape artist
and so
I I I I say to him you know by the way
there's this one painting and I describe
the painting I had seen over 10 years
ago and he said well that was way before
my time but I bet Gail will know and I'm
like Gail you know Gail he's like of
course I know Gail she like lives in in
down the road here's her number so for
two I paced around the apartment with
500 bucks in my pocket driving Chris
crazy cuz I felt like what am I going to
say to her and I must be a weirdo I've
been stalking this lady I've been
thinking about her for 10 years I can't
afford a painting you know what who am I
to buy a painting like what the hell so
finally Chris is like would you call her
or I'm going to call her you're driving
me crazy so I call her and I start
talking a mile a minute and she was
amazing and then um I said by the way
there was this one painting and I go and
I explain this painting there's a stand
of popler trees down the center and a
big mountain scape behind it and this
beautiful blue Vermont sky and geese
flying in formation overhead and I could
hear her thinking on the other end of
the line and she said you know Mel I've
done so many large
scale uh paintings over the years I'd
hate to mistake the one you're talking
about but I'll tell you what what if my
husband and I meet you and Chris at the
Mill at Simon Pierce
and we'll walk all around and have lunch
and I'll tell you the stories behind
every painting and if you don't see what
you like there I'll take you back to my
studio which is a couple miles down the
river and you can look at everything I'm
working on and if you don't see anything
you like there then you can go through
all my slides and see if you can find
that painting that you saw 10 years ago
and I said deal so a month passes we go
up to the mill I walk in we meet each
other she's amazing she's like twice our
age just incredibly cool lady she's
walking around as we're walking around
looking at these paintings Rich I've got
I'm like 8 months pregnant I'm realizing
these are 10 times the amount of money
that I have MH I can't afford this like
I don't I don't have this kind of
money and I'm getting like more and more
into that impostor syndrome what am I
doing mode oh my God I'm so embarrassed
I'm meeting somebody I ID a lies I don't
deserve to be here right wasting her
time because she thinks she's going to
get a Payday out of this correct we sit
down and she goes now that you're
sitting down I have something to tell
you
um she said there's only been two times
in my career as an artist that I've done
two studies of the same
piece and your painting is one of them
it's one of a
pair she knew all along she knew all
along she was playing games with you
about not knowing which painting yeah
and she said the sister piece to the one
that you saw all those years ago is
sitting in my studio right now where
it's been for the past 11
years I start sobbing everybody's like
totally emotional her husband's like you
should have seen her when you when she
was on the phone with you it was like
she saw a ghost so we get in the car and
we drive to the mill and when we walk in
they're in the center this massive kind
of Barn Studio space is an easel with a
painting taped up with painters tape on
it and it was the sister to my painting
there were slight differences not as
much movement in the grass but it
was one of the most extraordinary
experiences of my life it was as if time
suspended and I was standing before that
painting in
1990 saying it would be
and there I was 11 years
later standing in front of it and then I
realized oh my God I can't afford this
and Chris walks over and he's like
what's wrong and I'm like just promise
me someday like promise me that I don't
need a a jewelry I don't need a car like
just promise me you will buy me this
thing and he kind of leans over and goes
hey Gail how much for the big one and
she said um Mel can have it for 500
bucks cuz clearly when I was making it
11 years ago I was making it for
her
yeah and so it hangs in my kitchen it's
on the back of the book um this is the
galy though right so wait is it in the
is it in I think so yeah yeah and um
it's a reminder every day that your mind
is designed to help you get what you
want I never stopped believing that I
could make it happen and when you tell
your mind what's important to you there
is extraordinary
science that proves that your mind has a
live and everchanging filter a live
Network that changes how it views the
world What it lets in what it blocks out
and if you program your mind correctly
and if you're clear about what you want
to create your mind will help you get
what you want I know you all have big
goals Big Dreams big aspirations just
like I do you've got Ambitions to become
an amazing person to build your career
to create to contribute to give to be an
awesome human being but all of that is
impossible without great habits setup if
you don't have routine and structure set
up in a way that will keep you on track
then you you'll fall off and and and
having new goals without new habits is
kind of like you know having a new car
without wheels you know the habits are
the wheels they're the things that make
you able to achieve the goals so you got
to have good habits but the challenge
for most people isn't that knowledge I
mean you know you need to have good
habits it's you can't keep the Habit
going right have you ever started it the
new year you're going to get healthier
and you start that habit of working out
on a more regular basis and then it goes
away or you say you know I'm going to be
more kind and more patient and more
awesome to my partner my lover and you
start being nice for two or three days
and then on the fourth day you're a jerk
you know and you're like what what
happened I said I was going to be nicer
it's that you didn't set up the most
important thing you needed to maintain a
habit so what's the biggest secret I've
learned in almost 20 years in this field
it's so simple but most people don't
have it it's called trigger moments you
have to set up trigger moments to
activate your habits what do I mean by
that well let's say you want to become a
better person you know you want to
become more kind
more patient more loving with people now
you can just set that intention or write
that down in your vision your journal or
set up on a vision board that you look
at once in a while but in daytoday life
it's not enough you need things to
trigger you to remind you to be that
particular kind of person right it's
almost like if you could have a little
angel speaking in your ear all day long
to tell you what to do and how to be
you'd obviously become better well that
makes sense well let's use that idea
let's use that idea by setting up alarms
on our phones that trigger us to do the
very things we need to do this is going
to be so basic you're going to laugh and
then I'll also tell you how I've
literally taught this to Fortune 50 CEOs
and they said it was the one thing that
changed their life the most dramatically
so let's start with this let's I have a
goal in mind let's say you want to
become more present and calm throughout
the day again you could write that down
on a journal I'm going to be more
present and calm you could meditate 8 in
the morning saying today I'm going be
more present and calm and you you could
you can start out with good intentions
but those fall apart without a trigger
moment set up throughout the day to
remind you that so what if you did this
what if you just set up on your phone
three alarms during the day with a label
that said close your
eyes take 10 deep breaths in remind
yourself to be calm so let's say you're
going through your day it's crazy right
it's 10:00 a.m. and all a sudden Bing
your phone goes off you look down and it
says close your eyes take 10 deep
breaths and then again it happens at
2:00 and again it happens at 6:00 p.m.
and again it happens at 8:00 p.m. what's
going to happen you always look at your
phone don't you it's going to go
throughout the day you're going to
forget and the funniest thing is I've
had so many people do this worldwide
we're talking about hundreds of
thousands of people I've taught to do
this hundreds of thousands and they tell
me all the time that that changed
everything and you'll think once you set
it up that the next day you you'll you
you'll forget about it no that alarm
will go off you forgot you set the dang
alarm there it goes off in your face and
you're like all right I'm trying to be
calmer and more present close my eyes
take 10 deep breaths reground myself
here we go you can't do it once a day
you have to have moments throughout the
day that trigger you to enact the new
Behavior I know this makes sense to you
but it's a challenge for a lot of people
cuz they never set those things up so
what if you did it with an alarm so for
example for me on the opposite Spectrum
I don't want to just be calmer and more
present I Want More Energy throughout
the day so here's what I do one of my
big trigger moments is every time my
butt hits a chair I don't care if I'm on
a plane or I was like where we're
shooting here I I wrote a lot of my
books here I wrote the motivation
Manifesto here I wrote The Charge here
and if I'm going to write my butt hits
the chair I grab my phone I open the
timer and I set 50 minutes now at 50
minutes the timer goes it starts buzzing
and I look at that and I go oh that's my
trigger to get energy so I stand up I go
get some water I take a glass of water
drink it down I do some stretches and I
do some exercise just really briefly or
I'll go for a walk whatever it is but
I'll do something that usually takes
just 2 to 5 minutes then I'll sit back
down I'll set that 50-minute alarm and
I'll work and what that does is every 50
minutes it triggers me to change how I'm
physically moving it changes my
attention
so that throughout the day I'm
continually refreshed so I never have
that 2 3 4:00 time where I'm like ah you
know why because I've triggered my day
so that my energy is maintained
throughout the day makes sense right
this could be as simple as let's say you
want to be healthier in your life okay
let's set up some trigger moments for
you in this way let's say every time you
drop off the kids on the way back to the
house you stop at the grocery store and
get some fresh produce that's just a
trigger it's like okay did one thing
drop kids off now tied to that triggered
from that action drop kids off is go to
health food store or let's say you want
to get healthier in the morning one of
the easiest ways to help people maintain
a better exercise program is this set a
trigger you wake up in the morning your
first action is to drink water put your
exercise shoes on uh might get dressed
if you were naked just saying so you get
dressed put your shoes on you go
downstairs or you go to the gymm and
that's the trigger you woke up you do
these actions nothing interrupts those
actions that's the action and you have
to have those set up one of my other
favorite trigger moments to set up is
door frame triggers what do you mean by
that when you walk into a new room to
have a psychological trigger go off in
your mind that you've associated with
that door frame so let me give you an
example if I walk into my house at night
if I've been working all day and I'm
going to walk in I'm going to see my
lady I have it so when I ever walk
through the doors of my house three
words repeat off immediately in my mind
because I've done it so many times
consciously I went to the door I said
the three words said the three words
said the three words and I did this so
many times that now when I walk through
a door my mind automatically triggers
those three words and I remember to be
those three words so what words would
you love to have describe you as a
person that you would be happy if that
was how people described you what would
those words be have those and now set
them up in your life I teach Executives
to do this as well I have them have a
doorframe trigger when they walk into
their office in the morning soon as they
walk through that door frame they have
boom three words go through their mind
about how they want to be perceived as a
leader I have them set up another door
frame every time they walk into a
meeting into the conference room when
they walk through the doors of the
conference room they have another 3word
that trigger off for them and it just
reminds them how to be so these aren't
big crazy things a lot of people think
they have to completely change your life
what would change your life completely
is setting up more trigger moments and
associations that when you see something
you do this that when this action is
taken then that happens that when you uh
have the opportunity to set up alarms on
your phone you set them up so that
you're interrupted in your everyday life
to remind yourself to stick to the
habits to stick to the intention you do
that enough on a continual basis you'll
find yourself in so many ways completely
rejuvenated and I promise you'll stick
to your habits even more and once you do
that you know that everything changes
one of the things that will help you to
do the work to create the things that
you want in your life is it will help
you if you train your mind to start
spotting evidence as you're doing the
work as you're going through your day it
will help you if you train your mind to
start scanning the world and spotting
evidence that yes indeed the world is
sending you positive signals that things
are going to work out now why is it
important to train your mind to help you
get what you want well the reason why is
because if you get into a negative
mindset if you start
thinking this business is never going to
work why even bother or I'm never going
to meet anybody it's nothing but losers
out there look at all these idiots on
hinge why the hell should I keep doing
this if you allow your mind to start to
rest in a pessimistic negative
protective scared and doubtful stance
your mind will continue to show you
reasons why there's nobody on hinge
worth talking to your mind will continue
to show you all the reasons why you will
never make it in business your mind will
continue to show you all the reasons why
you're never going to lose that weight
and be able to tuck in your shirt as my
friend Karin Crabtree always talks about
that transformational moment and when
your mind goes negative your mind starts
to scan the world and will show you more
reasons to stop and the power of
training your mind to spot positive
signs is very simple the power is that
your mind will start to show you reasons
to keep going your mind will help you
take the step your mind will encourage
you to feel optimistic to feel empowered
just like you woke up today on a Tuesday
and it was February 22nd 2022 and those
numbers are lining up and that makes you
in your heart and soul Go whoo something
cool could happen today like that only
happens like once in my lifetime those
numbers are going to line up like that
today is a really cool day let's go do
something with this you could create
that kind of attitude every single
freaking day of your life you could if
you train your mind and if you start
taking action and training your mind is
the key piece that we're going to talk
about so for those of you that have read
the high five habit one of the things
that I talk about a lot is every single
day find a naturally occurring
heart-shaped object in the world it
could be a stone it could be a leaf it
could be a cloud it could be a shape in
your coffee hey Chris if we've got
anything around here that looks like a
heart hand it to me and the reason why I
love telling you to start playing a game
with yourself where you start your day
going mind brain show me some heart oh
what is this come here dog treat oh my
God it's a dog treat look at this
guys what shape is that that right there
is a
heart there we go check that out if you
say brain mind show me a heart today
guess what's going to happen that damn
dog biscuit it's going to show it's
going to you're going to be like there's
a heart you're going to look out at the
sky and you're going to see a heart
shape oh right there in the mountains
there's a heart shape in the mountains
in southern Vermont you're going to see
it in the clouds what you're doing when
you tell your mind what's important to
you is you're telling your mind and the
filter in your brain to change in real
time and allow into your
Consciousness what's important to you
and if you want to see hearts by God
those damn dog treats are going to start
looking like hearts everybody that's how
you train your mind it's freaking
incredible and if you want to see
evidence of this follow me on social
media if you follow me Mel Robbins on
social media you will see every day I am
reposting your stories of finding heart
shapes around the world now why is this
important well it's important because
it's it's a simple way to prove to you
that your mind changes in real time that
if you get serious about becoming more
positive and optimistic and encouraging
of yourself if you get serious about
saying this I don't want to see all the
reasons why I'm unhappy I don't want to
see uh everybody else in the world
that's launched a business or that's
lost weight and is healthy or that has a
really good uh marriage or relationship
and I don't want to see that and and and
have my mind process it as evidence that
it's never going to happen for me I want
my mind to reprogram itself and see
other people's businesses and see other
people getting healthy and see other
people in relationships and I want my
mind to say yeah if they can do it I can
do it that's evidence if that person can
get healthy so can I if that person can
find somebody on hinge so can I if that
person can Recon recile with their child
so can I other people can become
evidence that you can have it too right
now your mind is so up from your past
that when you see what other people have
and you don't have it you can't actually
translate it through a negative mind and
and see that that's evidence that you're
going to win you see it like oh somebody
already stole what I wanted that sucks
and so what I want to start to open your
mind to is that you have the power to
train your mind
to filter the world differently just
like you woke up and you saw the date
today 22222 and your brain saw that and
was like whoa this is a once- in
a-lifetime day
everybody you are never going to have
another day that lines up like this ever
what are you going to do with this day
your mind already interpreted this as
wow something cool could happen and if
you tell yourself something amazing is
going to happen
today something will because you're
going to be looking for it I swear to
God something will something will if you
want to see the good all around you you
got to tell your mind you want to see
the good and this just isn't a bunch of
hores everybody this isn't toxic
positivity there is a filter in your
brain called the reticular activating
system the reticular activating system I
call it the RAS I like to think about it
like a giant hairnet on your head and
this Ras sits over your brain I'm
probably getting this wrong I'm not a
neuroscientist I could give a sh about
getting it right I just need you to know
the basics here so that you can apply it
to your life okay you don't need a PhD
to use the science that super smart
people have been working really hard on
in order to apply it to your life that's
what I'm here for in your life I'm here
to translate this stuff into simple
believable and actionable things that
you can do to take all this super cool
stuff that people are researching and
apply it to your normal person's
everyday life to help you change from
the inside out and one of the coolest
things that you have at your disposal is
you have a whole system in your body
that you can train and change and one of
those things that you can train and
change that is impacted by that real
that word you're hearing a lot of
neuroplasticity that just means that
things are able to twist and Bend and
change and you're able to learn new
things for as long as you're alive as
long as you're breathing everybody you
got a chance to change the way that you
think as long as you are breathing you
got a chance to change from the inside
out how you experience your life as long
as you are still here watching me people
you got a chance to create a new
experience in your life and one of the
things that helps a lot is understanding
that right now all of the from
your past has jammed the filter in your
mind body and spirit the reticular
activating system and it is clouding
your ability to look at the world around
you and see hearts remember this dog
treat hearts look at that there's a
heart right
there because you made it this far in a
video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you are different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
as a special celebration if you put a
hasht believe down in the comments Below
on this video I will showcase you and
celebrate you somewhere on the screen in
a future video because you are awesome
to brainwash yourself and manifest in
your life check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there how many people in this audience
just curious believe in the idea that
the way you think has some effect on
your life just curious so you believe on
some level that your thoughts